les presentamos las noticias de economía
en francés 24 de la mano de jorge
hurtado jorge un saludo nuevamente
igualmente angela vamos a iniciar
hablando de las consecuencias de la
guerra en ucrania pero en américa
latina-asia si es que según el fondo
monetario internacional- esta guerra va
a empeorar la situación inflacionaria en
latinoamérica por la presión que está
generando sobre todo en los precios de
la energía así lo confirmó la directora
gerente del fondo cristalina georgieva
quien recordó que la inflación en muchos
países latinoamericanos se estaba
disparado antes de la guerra en ucrania
pero el aumento en los precios de la
energía repercutirá en los precios al
consumidor algunos países exportadores
de alimentos podrían ver la guerra como
algún tipo de oportunidad para aumentar
sus exportaciones pero no estén a salvo
de los riesgos inflacionarios la
funcionaria también destacó que la
escasez de fertilizante de los que rusia
y belarús son grandes exportadores
afectarán a los cultivos en la región
sobre todo en países como brasil que es
uno de los mayores importadores de
fertilizantes del mundo jorge a
propósito de alimentos la guerra en
ucrania está provocando una de las
peores crisis de alimentos y también de
materias primas en él así es por ejemplo
los índices generales de los precios de
las materias primas aumentaron un 26%
desde el inicio de 2022 los precios del
gas en europa casi se han triplicado por
el temor de una interrupción del
suministro otro de los commodities al
alza es el níquel usado en la
fabricación de carros eléctricos su
precio se ha disparado hasta el punto
que londres interrumpió su
comercialización el petróleo vive
jornadas volátiles en los mercados esto
porque rusia exporta alrededor del 7 por
ciento del suministro global según
goldman sachs la interrupción de
petróleo en rusia por la guerra en
ucrania estaría entre las más grandes de
la historia algunos expertos prevén que
la inflación mundial que ronda
actualmente el 7 por ciento puede
aumentar entre 2 y 3 puntos porcentuales
más hasta llegar a niveles no vistos
desde
1990 el temor es que esto genere
protesta e inestabilidad ayer angela
comentábamos por ejemplo que ya se
dieron las primeras manifestaciones por
el precio del poder por el alza en los
precios al sur de irak
bueno pero también hay más noticias
sobre no solo este conflicto sino
también otros temas económicos de
interés mundial así que si es que rusia
podría caer en bancarrota por las
sanciones económicas y las restricciones
financieras de occidente según el fondo
monetario internacional el conflicto
puede tener fuertes consecuencias para
la economía global estados unidos
registró un 79 por ciento de inflación
interanual en febrero la más alta en 40
años la cifra es una antesala de una
mayor subida en marzo cuando los efectos
de la guerra en ucrania se vean
reflejados la petrolera peruana
petroperú dijo que la mayoría de los
precios de los combustibles aumentarán a
partir de hoy entre un 5% y un 13% esto
como consecuencia de la guerra en
ucrania en argentina la cámara de
diputados votó por el acuerdo de
reestructuración de deuda de 45.000
millones de dólares con el fondo
monetario internacional mientras en los
alrededores decenas de manifestantes
protestaban en contra y se enfrentaron
con la policía esa manifestación fue
convocada por organizaciones de
izquierda y movimientos sociales
y vamos a terminar con una noticia bien
interesante en colombia hay una empresa
dedicada a la fabricación de ropa
blindada y está confeccionando para
salvar vidas en ucrania así es se trata
de emshi armor reconocidos por
confeccionar prendas de seguridad a
nivel mundial están llenos de pedidos
ahora por donaciones para ucrania según
su dueño miguel caballero desde su
fábrica ubicada a las afueras de bogotá
cosen pegan pintan arman y entregan
productos que buscan proteger la vida de
las personas escuchamos que en los
últimos días por el tema de ucrania se
ha incrementado el consumo están
comprando placas de nivel superior
chalecos porta placas de cascos para
temas balísticos cascos blindados y
entonces en esa misma línea ucrania se
volvió uno de los clientes más
importantes para nosotros a través de
empresas privadas que hacen donaciones y
se las entregan a civiles ya las fuerzas
militares del gobierno ucraniano vamos
por favor a los indicadores de las
hordas bueno aunque la world tour y
cerró en negativo por el mal dato de la
inflación que alcanza un máximo de
cuatro décadas en europa la bolsa de
parís cerró negativo y su principal
índice de valor es el cac-40 cayó un 2
83 % tras el fuerte impulso anotado del
7 por ciento del día de ayer la bolsa
mexicana de valores retrocedido por el
mal dato de la inflación en eeuu
recordemos que esas economías pues están
de ciertas formas vinculadas jorge el
agradecimiento para usted ya nuestros
televidentes de pedirles que continúen
con nosotros ella volvemos con más
noticias
[Aplausos]
[Música]